je vous invite
vous faire une opinion définitive à
attendre avec patience
que les chiffres des grandes villes
remonte pour qu'on sache vraiment nous
en sommes
quoi qu'il en soit
nous observons qu'une fois de plus nous
aurait été sous-estimée avant et moins
pendant
mais pour être
à la mesure du moment
même si nous n'avons pas de résultats
suffisamment défini pour pouvoir les
commenter utilement
voyons ce qui se présente
c'est une situation totalement inattendu
absolument inouïe la déroute du parti
présidentiel est totale et aucune
majorité ne se présente
nous avons réussi
l'objectif politique que nous étions
donnés en moins d'un mois de faire
tomber celui qui avec autant d'arrogance
avait tendu le bras tout le pays pour
être élu sans qu'on sache pourquoi faire
la france
s'est exprimé et il faut le dire
insuffisamment le niveau de l'abstention
est encore beaucoup trop ce qui signifie
qu'une immense partie de la population
ne sait de quel côté se tourner tant et
si bien que les trois blocs qui était
apparu à la sortie de l'élection
présidentielle
continue à être voisins dans des
proportions quasi identique sans qu'on
sache à cette heure si la percée de la
nuque le place en première ou en
deuxième position
mais c'est au total est avant tout
l'échec électoral de la macro ni
c'est l'échec
plus grave
les sexes moral
de ces gens qui donnait des leçons à
tout le monde sans arrêt et qui se
prétendait le barrage à l'extrême droite
et qui auront pour principal résultat
d'en avoir renforcé les rangs et sur 65
face à face entre la nulle
et le rassemblement national
les donneurs de leçons de la macro ni
ont été incapables de donner une
consigne claire dans 52 cas
ce qui le disqualifie
me semble-t-il dorénavant à faire de
leçon morale pour qui que ce soit
quel bon débarras
d'avoir vu après monsieur blanc caire
éliminé dès le premier tour
voir éjecter les baigneurs castaner
et injurieuses montchanin
vous tous
mon message ce soir une fois de plus est
un message de combat des opportunités
incroyables vont se présenter devant
vous et en particulier devant vous la
jeune génération qui est celle qui
appelle avec le plus de force à la
rupture avec ce monde et ses règles
d'organisation
des opportunités
parce que vous disposez d'un magnifique
outil de combat dont vous aviez été
privé pendant tant de temps cet outil
c'est la nuque ce sont ces
parlementaires
ouvriers et ouvrières
salariés de plusieurs ordres de toutes
les régions de france
arrivant par dizaines sur les bancs de
l'assemblée nationale
le maquereau nine ne s'est pas seulement
mis en faillite lui-même il a plongé le
pays dans une impasse et tout à l'heure
déjà nous avons entendu qu'il s'agissait
de dépasser les clivages
il n'y a aucun arrivage a dépassé avec
nous parce que nous ne sommes pas du
même monde nous visons pas les mêmes
objectifs nous n'avons pas les mêmes
valeurs nous ne croyons pas aux mêmes
futur
et comme nous pensions qu'ils le savent
alors nous en concluons qu'il se prépare
à d'autres entend peut-être toujours est
il que si nous sommes à la fin de la
soirée là nul acquis par diverses
manoeuvres on a déjà commencer par
retirer quasiment 21 députés d outre-mer
et à commencer par ceux de la réunion ou
six sièges sur sept sont emportés par
des députés qui d'autre a conscience un
gouvernement gagne
je veux vous dire
que toutes les possibilités sont dans
vos mains
tota moi
je change de poste de combat mais mon
engagement et demeurera jusqu'à mon
dernier souffle dans les premiers de vos
rangs si vous le voulez bien
le bronze jaillissement
[Applaudissements]
ah
puis le grand jaillissement de
l'histoire du plus profond de ce qu'est
la france des rébellions et des
révolutions oui ce grand jaillissement
dorénavant un visage le visage de notre
collectif celui de l'union populaire
les défis les plus inouïes vont
s'accumuler devant vous que ce soit le
changement climatique que ce soit la
grande crise financière
par quelque côté que vous voyez ce monde
finissant
c'est à chaque fois des réponses
fulgurante qu'il faudra apporter pas un
instant nous ne renonçons à l'ambition
d'être ceux qui gouvernent ce pays et
qu'il amène un autre horizon pas un
instant les salariés ne baisserons les
bras face à l'instant les jeunes ne se
diront
fatigué de la nuit
[Applaudissements]
ne doutez pas de vous même
ne cédez jamais à l'impatience
penser que chaque difficulté à deux
visages celui qui s'oppose à vous et
celui de l'opportunité qu'elle vous
propose
plus grands sont les bouleversements
plus grandes sont les opportunités
la france est une nation politique quand
bien même elle s'abstient beaucoup et
même quand elle le dit par son
abstention
ne méprisons jamais notre peuple et qui
tombe toujours avec attention tout ce
qu'il dit car dans sa patience infinie
il a montré qu'il était capable de
trancher et de décider d'avancer et tel
est le mandat que vous avez ce soir
demain matin peut-être que vous vous
réveillerez avec une majorité de la nu
par l'assemblée nationale
ou bien avec le premier groupe
aucun tripotage aucun arrangement
non nous privera de cette possibilité et
si ce n'est pas le cas alors vous
regarderez d'abord la puissance
formidable que vous avez accumulé vive
la france vive la république
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]